je suis gentil retrouva ou et non un
parc japonais voilà c'est plus
intéressant que les toilettes suis
d'accord avec vous je taxe prévue j'ai
repéré un petit stand avec des pédalos
et débarqué on va tout de suite aller
dedans c'est ça qu'on veut faire on est
des enfants aujourd'hui c'est parti
tétouan bordel à ce prix a fait une
erreur on voulait prendre un pédalo
s'ils grognent cyprien voulait prendre
une petite barque nul du coup ils rament
ça s'appelle la justice ait des gens qui
font de la bonne mais tu as oui oui oui
je prend le contrôle du navire
on a 1 9 km attention un demi-tour la
juste celle de droite tu vois là on est
six fois moins 20 degrés pendant 20
minutes on est arrivé là c'est vraiment
de m on n'est pas prêts là le cerisier
opération flore de cerise et réussi
bravo mais ça tout ce bonheur et une
boîte qui venaient de gaza qu'on arrête
de fumer ce tour comme ça mais deux mois
et non pas au dessus on la regarde elle
achoppe kaka ac est vraiment tombé juste
là s'étaient amusés mais qu'il a échoué
dans la nuit tombée dans l'eau et il est
tombé dans l'eau mais qui tu sais quoi
c'est celle que de déranger
on va être à très vite sur la terre
ferme
nous sommes devant le temple tout chaud
vous voilà avec une porte adoptant le
style chinois c'est marqué juste ici
penser que c'est intelligent je possède
mon ticket pour pénétrer dans l'enceinte
ces jolis seins ses poteaux là ça c'est
l'arbre sacré et pense qu'il fait à peu
près à vue d'oeil comme ça par 5 mètres
de haut il lui m de diamètre c'est
vraiment le seul arbre monde à porter
une ceinture si vous pensez que j'avais
l'oeil c'est faux voilà la bête c'est
beau hein
c'est très joli ça par exemple c'est un
arbre non sacré ça doit vraiment tout de
suite tu attendes tout à l'heure mais vu
de l'autre côté risqués sur moi pas un
peu du lourd ceci est incroyable s'est
excusé oui c'est bien ça super content
vous allez ça va c'est cool va voilà ont
visité tous les deux la même maison je
vais l'acheter aussi c'est pour ça que
ouais ouais je mets un type ou après les
mâles si tu trouves que winneway les
mannequins tu es mal desservies ses
magasins bûcher lacrymo et il est
maintenant l'heure d'aller akihabara le
quartier geek et otaku de tokyo
autrement appelée électrique car c'est
l'endroit où il faut être
quand on a un retour de geek à tokyo on
va aller faire un petit ufo catcher dans
pas longtemps c'est parti pour gagner
petites figurines
pour bien respecter son la croche de la
pince on est bien on est bien
dans la merde savoir qu'il te l'a revêtu
totalement la voix
oui
une figurine de pervers c'est maintenant
l'heure de s'affronter sur un petit jeu
de tam tam
on s'apprête à faire des jo la matrice
et s'avère côté apparaît extrêmement
porteur
mais la batterie dans la vraie vie ce
matin sur la blague en 3 2 1
marc vsd la gueule 553 coût de celui-ci
fait à fait rien j'ai fait 228 il a fait
ça cent mille pour celles actuellement
dans l'endroit le plus beau plus glauque
d'europe ya par exemple c'est la période
une femme c'est l'intérieur d'un argent
c'est très étrange ici vous assure
qu'est ce que c'est que ça qui achète
cet objet pour quoi faire
pourquoi son ventre est ouvert il ya
trop de trous noirs cette chose ça donne
très envie quand même certains de mes
pieds tous les acheteurs pieds si vous
voulez insérez votre pénis dans un pied
c'est possible si c'est vraiment glauque
on a trouvé l'objet le plus glauque
apprécié cette poupée aller voir un
docteur
voilà un chat
des chiens partout que c'est pas si vous
arrivez en trouver regardez
ceci est un char près
oui fait la gueule le tour 2009 qui
explose
la chute du char au terek tu me passes
dessus et ils sont vraiment gros ces
gens leurs poils et très soyeux
m
jumbo je ramène un nouveau petit frère à
la maison
ils sont tous en train de s'empiffrer
derrière ce c'est génial que sharon la
gamelle des zones sans aucun respect
bonne chance qui atteint de ce blog
étant de se dire a dit adieu s'emballer
coup une fois de plus n'hésitez pas à
lui mais ça vous a plu pour se retrouver
dans une prochaine porte et devient
tueur de monde
pis